if there's one thing about my message
that I constantly challenge you to do is
to not be naive and not fall for
everything no matter what people say
including myself or anybody else go
process it for yourself do your own due
diligence your own research but do not
fall for BS there's a man named Robert
Reich who is done a lot of work with the
government he's worked under Gerald Ford
Jimmy Carter Clinton Obama went to Yale
got all the fancy degrees can't stand
capitalism except when it works for him
and uh he's pretty much a socialist he
calls out every capitalist every chance
he gets secretly I'm convinced this guy
hates anyone who's a billionaire he
tweeted something last week that I
responded to and I asked him a question
whether we should be concerned about
this or not and I want to get your
thoughts on it and by the way if you get
value from this video and it gets you
thinking give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel so here's a
tweet Robert Wright tweeted out the
following since 1978 CEO pay has
increased by 1460 yes you read that
correctly so don't tell me that
corporations can't afford to pay workers
higher wages and provide decent benefits
as if they're not doing that currently
today however I responded back with my
own set of questions whether I should be
concerned about this or not and here's
what my response was to Robert Wright
I'd like to get your thoughts on three
additional stats average NBA player
salary has increased from 1978 till
today by 9 400 percent College tuition
has increased by fourteen hundred
percent and last but not least you make
a hundred thousand dollars an hour for
your keynote that's more than 99.9 CEOs
make in America should we be concerned
so watch this here I want you to
actually test this out go do it call a
speaking bureau today I would love it if
a thousand people did this and say how
much is Robert reich's rate for one hour
keynote then take that email and post it
all over Twitter and tag him and say why
should you get paid a hundred thousand
dollars an hour for being a professor
and a government employee how could you
ask for that dollar amount now here's
the problem I don't care if he makes 100
Grand a month a hundred grand an hour I
don't care if he charges 300 000 if the
Market's willing to pay for it I'm
totally fine with it heck pay the guy
three million dollars an hour if a guy's
able to get those kinds of eyeballs more
uh you know power to him NBA players
they used to make 40 Grand a year in
1978. you know what the NBA player's
average salary is today 8.8 million you
know what these guys do they play a game
can you imagine playing a game and you
make 8.8 million dollars for plain a
game and you're just playing a game is
there anything wrong with that nothing I
think today many NBA players are still
underpaid but the Market's going to
increase their value every single year
we're going to have a billion dollar
contract very soon for a player and
whoever that player is is probably worth
it because they bring a lot of eyeballs
and they make money the other one
college education has college tuition
that's increased nearly fifteen hundred
percent since nineteen seventy eight has
the actual education improved fifteen
hundred percent why are professors you
know knowing sitting there ex bashing
capitalism at the same time they're
seeing College tuition was nothing 40
some years ago now I'm paying forty
fifty thousand dollars to universities
that are sitting on tens of billions of
dollars of endowment
should we question that so A Robert
Reich a socialist who hates it when
capitalists become billionaires you know
but loves it when because of a
capitalistic Society he makes a hundred
thousand dollars an hour for a keynote
and he trashes people anytime you're
telling the story tell all sides of the
story there are many leaks in his
argument that a lot of people when they
read his tweet and they say wow it's not
fair that corporations are getting paid
this and CEOs are making all this kind
of money yeah but you know if
corporations get all that money you know
who else makes a lot of money do you
know how much more government is getting
today in tax revenue than they did in
1978 over a thousand percent what does
it mean the money evens out
whoever's making the money that's Co
they have to pay taxes because it's
ordinary income who all these
corporations that are creating all these
jobs and becoming trillion dollar
Enterprises they have tens if not
hundreds of thousands of employees that
pay taxes and everybody pays taxes they
bring Revenue the government doesn't
need to go out and create these jobs so
again anytime arguments like this are
given think about hundreds of thousands
of kids go to college and every year 13
professors believe what Robert believes
for every one Professor that believes in
pure capitalism that these guys are
doing great things what do you think
happens to these kids graduating from
colleges if you're going to college
right now and your professor talks about
Robert Reich ask the question I just
asked hey professor Johnson I I
understand what you're saying about
Robert reichen how corporations are
making more money than ever before do
you think it's fair that NBA player
salary has increased 9 400 percent since
1978. do you think it's fair that
College tuition has increased nearly
1500 since 1978. do you think it's fair
that the same Robert Reich you just
talked about made a hundred thousand
dollars a keynote I think it's okay but
should we be concerned about that as
well that professor is one going to kick
you out of the classroom too they're not
used to debating they're just used to
spewing out what they believe in because
nobody pushes back students have to
listen and take their stuff but the
reality is the final one next time you
hear a message like this go see what the
opposing argument is and then from there
make a decision for yourself if you only
listen to one side of stuff that people
are saying your argument doesn't get
stronger I interview Communists and
socialists because I see leaks in the
capitalistic argument where crony
capitalism gets gets involved and I also
see leaks in the socialism and communism
argument because it just takes a matter
of few minutes before they start seeing
their own leaks and then all of a sudden
they have to make stuff up and they're
getting stuck with their arguments that
they're making anyway so if you got
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel I got
two interviews I want you to watch one
is the leading socialist professor in
America according to Forbes Richard
Wolff loved my conversation with them if
you've never seen it we debate over
capitalism and socialism and the other
one is a professor Esther Blair from
Riverside who sits there saying the two
best leaders of the last hundred years
is Mao and you know who the other one he
talks about Stalin and he's a full-blown
communist professor and we had a
wonderful conversation together so if
you want to see this one communism click
here if you want to see the socialism
one click here either way have a great
day take care everybody
[Music]